so this the talk title there's a little
bit of a bait-and-switch that's probably
good enough anyway first and foremost if
you're having trouble seeing it the
presentations online if you're not
having trouble seeing it
don't go there there are a lot of images
and I don't want you to bog down the you
Wi-Fi anyway so this is actually more
accurate so I'm gonna be dressing jQuery
directly and I think it sounds like it's
kind of a popular opinion here to bag on
jQuery hopefully that doesn't sour you
on the talk to be more accurate this is
sort of faster better leaner jQuery in
certain aspects the slide just it just
doesn't really fit well long slide looks
kind of ugly so this is my personal
information that's where you can find me
on Twitter that's my blog github there
is more stuff on my blog about this and
I'll talk about that in a little bit but
generally on the internet you can find
me at John bender I work full time at
Adobe on jQuery Mobile I say that only
because I'm very lucky to have a job
work in an open source I'm very grateful
and Adobe pays me to work on a great
project so I'm happy to be doing that so
what is the motivation for this talk so
this is something I feel like I have to
cover a lot of people ask me like why do
we care what does this matter so just to
make sure that you don't leave the door
in the next five minutes let's talk a
little bit about the motivation first of
all math is pretty awesome
so I've had kind of a tumultuous
relationship with it and I think a lot
of people have I think a lot of times
you come to math in terms of like
calculus or geometry and these things
aren't necessarily very interesting but
once you find something you really love
and you find a way to kind of apply
formalism to it math takes on a kind of
a different shape so that's a little bit
what this presentation is about jquery's
5 so this is not something I need to
repeat too often but jQuery gets used by
a lot of websites according to Alexa
rankings for whatever value you give
that the top 10 thousand websites
something like 50 percent of them 50
plus percent of them use jQuery the top
million it's like 45 percent so there's
a lot of people using jQuery so if we if
we get a big benefit out of this if the
application of category theory and
formalism
to jQuery provides some sort of benefit
there
they brought her brought her win there
everybody likes performance so this the
large a large portion of the benefit
that we get out of applying category
theory to jQuery is performance right so
everybody likes presentations about
performance uh incidentally that's
tachometer that says nothing at all
about how fast you're going so jQuery
let's talk a little bit about the
problem we're gonna kind of solve within
jQuery uh
so jQuery if you've ever used it before
which I'm sure how many of you have not
used jQuery okay
there's a couple of you all right good
I'll make this quick but I'll cover it
so would jQuery what you're generally
doing is you're getting elements out of
the Dom using something like this a
selector with a dollar function and then
you may call some method foo on it this
could be anything add classes remove
classes change properties and it's
chainable so it's a fluent interface and
this will become relevant later
so the internals of these jQuery methods
all have the form so if you're defining
foo they all take the form on the jQuery
prototype so if you're if you're
invoking it on a jQuery object it's not
actually calling anything on the jQuery
object it does a prototype lookup right
so it goes up the prototype chain to
find that function but they're all
invoked on a jQuery object right so the
the context in which they're operating
is a jQuery object and that's very
important that'll become relevant later
but generally what they do is they loop
over that set of elements or they don't
and they do some manipulation to it
that's that's the general shape of a
jQuery method more specifically there's
a large set of jQuery methods that deal
directly and manipulating the Dom
elements inside a jQuery set there are
some that don't so for example first
just truncates the set right it doesn't
do anything to Dom elements in it these
things do a whole lot of work so the
first thing they do is they generally
handle arguments so if you've ever used
a jQuery again if you've used jQuery
before you know that most methods have
like a gigantic type Union for each of
their arguments right they take strings
they take Dom elements they take
functions for callbacks they take other
jQuery objects they do a lot of argument
handling inside the method so this can
be complex extremely complex of times
additionally they also loop over the set
right so if you're going to manipulate
the Dom elements in the set you have to
loop over it and deal with it in some
some fashion or another and then that's
sort of the third thing that they do
they do some Dom element emulation right
that's mixed in there so this is kind of
this isn't bad per se especially with an
example that's what like five lines but
when you actually if you look if the 20
or so people who are in here earlier
have actually looked at the jQuery
source a lot of the methods are actually
quite large they're very complex so this
mixing this sort of mashing together of
the functionality of handling the
arguments doing the looping and dealing
with the Dom element alteration can get
untenable times so this is this is kind
of the problem we're gonna solve and
we're gonna solve it by applying some
category theory now when I say I'm gonna
work in category theory I'm not working
in monads okay I know everybody knows
has heard of a monad before learning how
to understand monads and Haskell is kind
of a cool and popular topic if you're a
programmer I'm gonna talk about a much
more basic introductory level type stuff
hopefully if you know JavaScript at all
you'll be able to get pretty much all of
this a little bit of background to guys
Alan burger McClane we're working with
groups we was working with algebras and
what they noticed was there's this
common there are these commonalities
between algebra is this stuff that they
were working in so like any programmer
worth their salt they took what they
were seeing that was the same and they
abstracted it out and this sort of
became the genesis for category theory
wild and crazy guys that they were so
because working in algebra is exciting
but that is what eventually became
category theory they just did what you
do every day when you see two things
that are doing the exact same operation
they pulled it out they made it
available so what is a category
specifically let's start by defining
what we're gonna be building here today
first it's two concrete things the set
of objects just concretely things and
it's a set of morphisms which are
actions or operations on the objects
right so a good example and then there's
two laws first law is identity so
identity is very simple for every object
in a category and just to be clear so
you can think of objects and morphisms
as the relationship between nouns and
verbs kind of right I think that that
analogy gets overused a lot in
programming but it's very optimistic
so the identity law is very simple it
just says that for every object in a
category there has to be some function
that will deal with that object and
return it as and not do anything so in
JavaScript this is very simple it takes
an argument returns argument unaltered
so that's identity the second is
composition this is the second law it
has to be here it has to provide for a
composition very simple if you had some
function G that takes today and gives
you a B you have some function f that
takes a B gives you C if you smoosh
those things together
you will end up with a function that
takes an A and gives you a see how many
of you have used underscore GS ok the
compose function that's that's what
we're looking at here so in JavaScript
again it's very simple take two
functions create a new function that
takes a single argument and then pipes
those through each of those functions
again you're just gluing the two things
together you're composing them
composition so this is the the fourth
thing that you need for a category so
let's start off we got two categories to
go through the first one we're gonna
cover as HTML now what I'm asking you to
do for the first part of this
presentation is sort of blindly follow
me through the formalism here and then
at the end we'll get to the really
awesome stuff like the performance
benefits and things the concrete things
that you could take home and talk to
your friends about if you were to talk
to your friends about category 3 so hTML
is our first category that the objects
in HTML very simple they're just Dom
elements stuff you get using the jquery
or not the jquery the javascript api for
the dom right so query selector returns
a single element from the dom based on a
selector right so the thing that you
would get from this this is these are
the objects of the category HTML when I
say objects I mean all possible
representations every possible Dom
element Everest fits into this set of
object it's a large set in morphisms of
HTML the verbs the actions are just
JavaScript functions that take HTML
elements and return them ok and in this
case we're gonna say a single element
and we're also sort of hand-waving here
right JavaScript doesn't have a type
system I mean there are compile to
JavaScript languages that do but in this
case we're talking about JavaScript and
we're gonna hand wave and say that to
play in HTML to play part in our game
here you have to take only HTML elements
and return
HTML oh man you can't take an HTML
element and return a string that
wouldn't be part of our category HTML so
an example very simple takes an element
sets the attribute class to Foo very
simple and then returns that same
element that is just alter okay
super simple so identity what is
identity
what is that identity function in HTML
again same thing the only difference is
we're forcing it to take a Dom element
and return one that's the only
difference
same thing with composed composes
exceptionally simple again the only
difference is Dom element not just any
random thing so that's it that's all
hTML is so we just in about two minutes
to find our first category how many of
you are totally unclear about the things
I just said okay right this is how
simple category theory is right it's not
at a very basic level it's so abstract
it's extremely simple right so we can
apply it to a lot of things and it's
applied all over the place in math and
and science and chemistry and all sorts
of wild places so let's look at one
that's a little more complex so let's
look at our second category the second
part of our formalism here is our
category jQuery so the objects of jQuery
are surprise surprise jQuery objects
okay so any jQuery object it could be
the empty jQuery object it could be one
with many elements the single element
doesn't matter so in the case of our
example here it's just one element well
ostensibly one element less you're
throwing ideas around your Dom like a
madman it's just it's just any Dom
elements wrap by jQuery object the
morphisms of jQuery are as you would
expect jQuery methods so anything on
vocht on a jQuery object that
manipulates the jQuery object is a
jQuery morphism very simple identity
just as you would expect very simple but
there's a slight twist so it has to be
defined on the jQuery objects prototype
jQuery dot FN okay we're stipulating
that because the requirement here
remember we said earlier that identity
had to take an argument and return one
right here so so here what we're doing
is we're sort of twisting that a little
bit we're sort I'm gonna hand wave and
say that the first argument is actually
the context of this value in this case
and if you know JavaScript well enough
you know that you can actually use
function dot apply and explicitly set
that this value so you can actually kind
of treat it like an argument but I'm
gonna hand wave here and say it's not
taking any arguments it's just gonna
deal with this and that's our first
argument so how does this work just as
you would expect you invoke ID on a
jQuery object and you get back the exact
same jQuery object okay simple
composition now composition is a little
more complex again then for HTML take
two jQuery methods now these aren't just
random functions anywhere these are
jQuery methods things that are Diet
defined on the jQuery prototype and
we're gonna take we're gonna recreate a
new function that will eventually be
assigned again to the jQuery prototype
and I'll show you an example in a second
but this is very simple it just going to
take the context of this value and it's
gonna pipe it through each of these
functions using apply does anybody
unclear on how apply works in JavaScript
awesome this is the perfect crowd for
this presentation all right it's so real
quick example if you have two jQuery
methods each of them dealing with this
value okay just like if you if you write
jQuery methods and they don't deal with
this value something's wrong so this is
this is what did you a query method is
you're composing them using our compose
function like this and we get a new one
gf and that ordering there is correct so
G will go first then F will go and what
we're saying is that as a result these
two things are functionally equivalent
we've smashed the two jQuery methods
together so that the G and the F for the
same as the composed version okay I want
you to remember this slide specifically
remember that when I say that the
composed version is identical to the
chained version that we're making an
example of here I'm gonna use that later
we're gonna talk about loop fusion okay
great anybody not anybody anybody not
gonna remember that GF is the same thing
as chained G DNF great this is a great
crowd cuz none of you raise your hands
so the last thing we're talking about is
a functor also if you have a better
slide background for a slide that says
functor on it you let me know I could
not find one I thought it was just a
really cool picture so a functor is a
purely category theoretic contract all
it does well all it does
little complex but all it really does is
get you from one category to another so
if you're playing around in HTML you're
using raw JavaScript functions to deal
with HTML elements and you want to get
into jQuery for whatever reason you want
to take that stuff you're working on and
get into jQuery you need a functor well
you don't need a functor I'm giving you
a functor as a consequence of this
because we're talking about category
theory but the point is that's what it
does so we're gonna go from HTML to
jQuery this is not bi-directional it's
unidirectional so we're only going from
HTML the jQuery so we need three things
for this honker first we need something
that translates objects in HTML to
objects in jQuery okay the second thing
we need is we need something that takes
the morphisms in HTML so those HTML
altering regular JavaScript functions
and turns them into jQuery methods or
the morphisms in jQuery and the last
thing we need to do there's a little bit
more detail to this but for the
presentation the last thing that we're
gonna do is we're gonna prove the laughs
law which is that it preserves
composition of morphisms okay that
sounds really abstract but it's actually
very simple so we'll talk about that so
for the objects very simple extremely
simple little known fact or depending on
who you are if you take a regular Dom
element you just if you sit you send
that as an argument to the dollar
function you get back a jquery set that
wraps that thing right so we've taken
our HTML objects and we transported them
into jquery quite simply all we had to
use was the dollar function okay so
that's the first part second part we got
to take the morphisms those jquery or
the HTML altering functions and turn
them into jQuery methods so if we take
our example set foo that just alters
that element adds the the classes foo we
what we really want to do is we want to
take something that that accepts as a
single argument an HTML element and we
want to turn it into this jQuery method
set foo this invocation right so this is
that we're sort of changing the
invocation pattern so how do we do that
well one really easy way to do that is
map so inside a jQuery method you have
to this and when you use map it just
iterates over that set of Dom elements
that's inside the jQuery object and
hands them off to whatever function you
gave it right so in this case I've kind
of hand waved and say and I've said it's
okay that the index
is an extra argument so that's that's
fine for now
but the with that all we had to do to
basically take our set foo which was
only concerned with HTML elements and
turn it into what amounts to a jQuery
morphism is apply map right so if you've
ever done list operations in other
languages obviously you're probably
familiar with map and it's very much the
same thing a list is actually this it's
a functor for all lists so that's all
its really doing here we so map becomes
our second bit so we have our two pieces
or two concrete pieces first the mapping
from the HTML objects to jQuery objects
and second a mapping from HTML morphisms
to jQuery morphisms okay so the last
thing is the WHA and this is the this is
there actually the really important part
this actually tells us almost everything
about the two categories we're gonna
care about so first remember we said
that when we smoosh these two things
together using compose to get GAF that
that was functionally equivalent to the
chain right okay the functor law
requires that in the case that in the
case where we use the underlying HTML
morphism so again remember I said that
in jQuery methods inside them is sort of
living this HTML altering thing right so
if we pull that out and we stuck those
together by themselves and we map that
over the jQuery set that would actually
be functionally equivalent to gnf right
so it's the equivalent HTML morphism so
what this is saying is that and and
interestingly enough that top thing is
two loops and the bottom thing is one
loop so that's a loop fusion right so
and it's still bounded by n but that's
less loops which is good it's less
operating you're creating less heat in
your processor so to speak anyway that's
what it's saying it's saying that the
raw composition using a map is the same
thing as chaining those two methods
that's the law that it here's the law
that that's what you get for free more
broadly speaking what this is actually
saying is that there's a really kind of
tight relationship between the category
HTML in the category jQuery or
colloquially between stuff that
manipulates HTML and stuff that
manipulates jQuery objects which you I
think you kind of understand intuitively
so this functor that that takes HTML and
turns it into jQuery the morphisms
actually there's a set of them
that depend on jQuery right so we
remember we said that inside the jQuery
methods that alter so let's take ad
class for example and well while and I
have another class here I have another
example here a second inside that is
living something that alters HTML
elements right so it does two things
really it alters the jQuery object then
it also alters HTML elements so in some
on some level it's dependent on some
external thing that could just be
altering the HTML elements so that's the
relationship that we got here so a
little if you wanted to do kind of the
ghetto map version or math version of
this it would be map plus some these
morphisms these HTML altering functions
equals some subset of the jQuery methods
that you've used every day right so you
can get all of those from map plus the
HTML morphisms so that's the
relationship as an example so inside foo
now that we have map and this thing that
alters HTML elements like I said there's
tons of there's tons of methods that do
this so add class after HTML prop they
all look like this on the inside now it
might be a little bit different they
might use each they might use while that
might use a for loop to loop over the
jQuery set but they all do this and then
alter the underlying HTML element so if
they're doing remember that they're
doing all these three things together
which is bad but what we've said is that
this relationship means that we can
actually pull out that HTML part right
so the relationship the functor between
these two things is actually telling us
that we can take that basic underlying
alteration and then the jQuery method
can only deal with arguments and looping
and leave the alteration to the Foo okay
leave it to the HTML morphism so we've
actually the formalism the category
theory aside from giving us loop fusion
has also given us a way to better
architect jQuery at an underlying level
when you're manipulating the Dom okay
and that's awesome so we're really happy
because this sort of solved our problem
the formalism the application of the
formalism has sort of solved our problem
for us great so I've just spent ok so I
just spent 20 minutes convincing you
just to blindly follow me through math
and formalism right so let's talk about
why you actually care first of all a
common idiom in so let's let the suit
okay and and I need you to assume for a
moment one thing
let's assume for a moment that jQuery in
an alternate universe or let's say an
alternate universe where I came to
jQuery before a year ago and I got I got
all gung-ho about category theory and I
decided I'm gonna go to jQuery and
separate all these out so the jQuery was
now providing the underlying
manipulation not as a part of the jQuery
method but as a part of a separate thing
that gets used in the jQuery method so
what would you get out of this
first of all rewrapping so rewrapping is
a pretty common idiom in JavaScript that
uses jQuery right so if you bind to a
function if you when you want to get the
target of the like a an event you use
event dot target and that is actually an
underlying thing that's an HTML element
right so you end up rewrapping this I
think you could use this in this case
also but if you didn't have to do that
or if you had foo the thing that
manipulated HTML elements directly you
wouldn't have to rewrap it right you
could just call foo directly on the HTML
element right simple you can simplify
your code a little bit there's a little
less cruft not a big deal just something
to keep in mind so Fusion remember we
said that this law meant that a chain
was the same thing as composing the
underlying alteration right so an
example if you have to remove attributes
in a chain that's actually you can
actually fuse this manually and this is
manual loop fusion using the underlying
thing that alters elements because
remember each each loops over the set of
jQuery the jQuery said and gives you
each HTML element so you can then
manipulate that directly so now you've
gone from two loops to one loop which is
good you avoid doing you know variable
incrementing you do you avoid doing
array access and a whole host other
things which in and of itself isn't like
mind blowing and I don't expect you to
read that up there but the blue bar is
when you're using loop fusion when
you're using the fused version and the
red bar is when you're not so when
you're just doing change so there's a
performance benefit that huge but it's
there I'm gonna say it's between 10 and
15% it's not it's more like 5 but that's
fine so we get some performance benefit
out of doing the loop fusion so that
that has a benefit getting getting
access to that that underlying thing
allows you to kind of smoosh these loops
invocation so in in jQuery methods there
are almost always an enormous number of
invocation patterns that you can use to
work with the same method so one example
the one I always kind of use and it's
actually a pretty simple example is
remove attribute so this example is
functionally equivalent to this you can
either change two of them or you can use
a white space separated list of
attributes that you want to remove so
and that's cool because it means you can
call remove attribute less but there's a
price to pay for doing that string
parsing right and then removing the
attributes okay that's not for free part
of jQuery is bent is that it has always
been about ease of use and not
necessarily always about performance but
those thing kind of things have a
trade-off right so if you just go in to
remove attribute and you tear out that
feature you get a pretty big performance
win in this case I'm gonna go ahead and
say it's twenty percent but it you can
see okay the the unfriendly version of
remove attribute is the red bar okay and
the friendly one is the the blue bar
it's faster okay it's better in terms of
performance now it's not better in terms
of usability right but if we if we
provided that remove attribute to
manipulate Dom elements and we just left
off all the invocation patterns you get
the performance benefit and you wouldn't
lose the other invocation pattern it's
just sort of a new new a newly exposed
API it wouldn't even increase the size
so that's one other benefit is
simplifying the manipulation of Dom
elements when you don't because you're
paying the if you're using jQuery and
you just use the chain version you're
paying the price for the other version
in terms of performance okay so what you
ideally would want to do is leave that
in place and provide a second API in
terms of the underlying HTML morphism
dog food inside jQuery there are tons of
methods that use other jQuery methods
for example and this is a very simple
example or simplified version of it but
replaced with uses at least two other
jQuery methods so it uses before and
remove or a pendant remove that means
that as if you optimize these things
there's or if you were to use the
underlying simplified version inside of
jQuery methods even just not exposing it
at all let's say we just decided to
react attack jQuery the jQuery methods
like this by them
selves you would actually see a
performance benefit faster the the split
version is on the bottom it's the red
and it's faster than the blue version
above it so you get you get a
performance benefit without actually
even providing anything new to anyone
else so jQuery would benefit this from
this in terms of performance laughs and
probably most importantly if you need a
performance escape hatch in your jQuery
code for whatever reason now I want to I
want to caveat most of this right now
with one thing most JavaScript
performance problems in the browser are
almost entirely due to things like
reflows and Dom manipulation all
JavaScript spends most of its time
inside the browser the execution time is
inside the browser it's not at the
JavaScript level and so that's why I
want to say before you run out and tell
everyone that we can fix the the world's
problems with these things that has to
be taken into consideration right at
some point javascript may actually
become bottleneck for you but most the
time it's in the Dom so before before I
give you a big performance number which
this is I wanted to caveat that so if we
if we expose this thing and you needed
it as a performance escape hatch for
example if you're doing a bunch of
element appending in your your your
jQuery code and this for whatever reason
was slowing down what you were doing you
could take this and convert it into a
while loop using the underlying append
right so the the previous example just
uses regular jQuery append right works
on a jQuery object the underlying one
requires HTML elements so if you do this
with like a tight while loop and you
take the if you extract the elements out
of the jquery set and then you append
whatever element you're appending
manually using this append you get a
gigantic performance improvement okay
and this is what I mean in terms of an
escape hatch now I don't know what the I
don't know what the percentage is I
think you're I think you can tell that
that's a big difference so the big one
at the top is the simplified one that
just uses the HTML morphism directly so
that's really pretty awesome again
assuming your bottleneck is in that
append it's really awesome and I think
that that's it's you know it's a single
threaded runtime you can always shave
some time off but how much time do you
want to spend on it personally and this
is something that I've discussed with
the folks in the jquery project too is
that they have a lot of things that they
need to do so it doesn't necessarily
make sense for them to spend all their
time on this
when most bottlenecks live outside of
the code so in light of the fact that
this is actually pretty cool and then I
like the idea
clearly I'm here presenting about it and
it doesn't seem like something that's
really reasonable for jQuery to do up
front I i work on the jquery team so i
have contact with the jquery core folks
if they have a lot of stuff on their
plate so I decided what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna do this myself I'm gonna
provide it as a separate library I'm
basically gonna steal the code out of
jQuery and provide those underlying
manipulations as sort of a Dom
manipulation macro set of macros just
some functions that make manipulation
easier if you don't need anything else
from jQuery also I have to give credit
to the folks who made Gilmore's this is
one of their images I think it's a great
picture fits with this slide so I also
don't want to get sued for using it so
this is available on github
I'm not hitting the cat I wasn't even
sure I wanted to do this when you guys
sent out the email about hitting the cat
it's not private anymore actually it's
public and you can take a look at it and
play around with it there's a couple
things that it's meant to do first of
all it's focused the goal is not to do
anything other than make very Dom
manipulation methods using the names
that you're used to from using jQuery
okay so the idea is that there's
supposed to be a pretty close one to one
relationship so when you say I want to
empty something you don't have to think
about what the name of the method is
right it's just empty and they're
provided just as methods by themselves
and generally speaking they return the
element that they're manipulating so you
can do that composition if you want to
it's functional so you know I am
providing the goal is just to provide
the method sort of the internals of
jQuery and sort of expose them but I'm
not you know crazy I think if you wanted
to use this as a standard library I'm
kind of trying to make that possible so
first of all for most there's a
namespace under which all these methods
live okay so you're just empty the
element it's very simple and it's
functional it's you just pass the things
in there's no objects it's not
object-oriented it's just a method you
can otherwise you can wrap it in a dhama
and in a in a wheeled Dom object and
then do things like chaining so there's
a nice kind of fluent interface if
that's what you feel like doing if you
want to use the Sustainable library and
lastly there's a very simple selecting
interface it defaults to query selector
where it's supported but you can plug in
things like
in this case is everybody know what
sizzle is okay so for those that you
don't at a jQuery selection engine it's
called sizzle and it's provided as a
separate library just gets used in
jQuery it's modular so every single one
of the methods I think this is old but
there's like 17 or 18 methods right now
they'll probably be more every single
one of them is an AMD module so I and
this is more for the build that I have
in place to to constructed and provided
as a single file but you don't have to
you don't have to keep any of them right
I wanted to see its kind of experimented
in radical modularity it's well tested
so I have a fork of jQuery where this is
actually being used in each of the
methods that they're mapped to so and I
runs and it runs in the test suite
jQuery test suite in passes so that was
one of my goals I want it to be jQuery
but not jQuery sort of its small
smallish I haven't made any effort at
all to keep it small in terms of
minification but with the Dom stuff like
the user friendly stuff it's about 1.5 K
and it's about 1.2 K with howdini the
user friendly stuff so the jQuery
version of this it's probably a little
bit less than that and it's some point
I'll go through and make it smaller I'll
- I'll make a pass to make it a little
bit tinier and it might get a little bit
bigger because I add methods lastly if
you're interested in in more of this I
have obviously Weald is on github you
can find it under my name space that's
the link my blog has other really nerdy
stuff about category theory so there's
actually a natural transformation that
lives inside of jQuery which is kind of
cool there's almost no benefit from it
but it's fun anyway
and I am sort of getting this together
in terms of like writing a paper about
it I have no illusions about it ever
getting published but there is
performance information there there's a
lot of links to J's perf there if you're
interested and that is category theory
and jQuery
you